please that you've joined us for today's
lecture it's on a timely topic a
trillion dollars of student loans a
crisis created by Washington that
question is in fact being taken up just
a couple of blocks from where the Kirby
Center is located as both houses of the
United States Congress are considering
whether to continue a lower rate of
interest for a particular class of
student loans we have today with us an
expert who's been writing not only on
this particular question and conducting
a lot of scholarly research on this
topic but on questions attendant to the
entire array of questions related to the
financing of higher education one
statistic and I'm sure there will be
many more in today's talk that I would
like to present to you is it relates to
Hillsdale College many of you might know
that the college is independent of any
taxpayer funding whether at the federal
or state level and we try to enable our
students to graduate with this little of
debt as possible and and through the
contributions of friends from around the
country private loans and and even more
a private grants are available to
students but when it comes to paying
back those debts Hillsdale College
students do so at an extraordinary rate
with a default rate hovering just over
one percent that compares to a statistic
much much higher I know that's been of
some debate and perhaps our speaker
today will shed some light on that to
introduce our speaker I'm going to call
upon Jim Dudley but before I do so let
me just make two quick notes one
importantly is that this lecture is
brought to you by the generosity of
Chris and Sarah Chuck Ola
alumni of Hillsdale College we are
grateful to them for making this
possible also if you are watching this
on the webcast you may send a question
that will be taken into consideration
then as part of our Q&A period which
will follow this lecture you may do so
by emailing us at First Fridays at
Hillsdale dot edu today to introduce our
speaker formerly is Jim Dudley for the
last semester Jim a veteran of the
United States Navy a graduate of
Villanova University has been doing
yeomen work as interned with the Kirby
Center and I'm pleased to call on him
now to introduce professor Vetter
Richard Vetter is the Ruth Kennedy
distinguished professor of economics at
Ohio University he also serves as a
senior fellow with the independence
Institute as a faculty associate with
the contemporary history Institute and
as an adjunct scholar at the American
Enterprise Institute his books include
out of work and going broke by degree
why college cost too much
he also publishes regularly in The Wall
Street Journal the Christian Science
Monitor National Review and investor's
business daily dr. Vetter received his
PhD in economics from the University of
Illinois today dr. Vetter will be
speaking on the topic a trillion dollars
of student loans a crisis created by
Washington please join me in welcoming
dr. Richard Vetter
thank you very much I must say I'm
delighted to be here today although I'm
somewhat surprised because I am an
economist an economists are often wrong
for example in writing in the New York
Times in mid October of 1929 the Dean of
American economists Irving Fisher of
Yale said and I quote mr. Fisher the
stock market is on a permanently high
plateau it promptly began the biggest
crash in American history falling 85
percent over the next three years in
1985
they've Nobel Prize Keynesian economists
a great reputation Paul Samuelson of MIT
said in his iconic textbook and I quote
the Soviet planning system is a powerful
engine for economic growth seven years
later we had no Soviet Union much less
planning system which has never was very
powerful any way except anything except
causing misery in 2009 the chair of the
Council of Economic Advisers Christine
Romer opined that the Obama stimulus
package if it were past unemployment
would never pass 8% it promptly
increased to 10% and is above 8% more
than three years later so you are now
forewarned in the I am a longtime
admirer of Hillsdale College I must say
however in candor that Hillsdale has
given me a lot of headaches over the
years but for a very good reason
my research center the Center for
college affordability and productivities
does the rankings of undergraduate
colleges for Forbes magazine in
Hillsdale has ranked very highly in
those rankings by the way but unique
among the 650 schools we look at
Hillsdale does not report a wide variety
of data to the United States Department
of Education
because it has taken the principled
stand that it wants to have as few
dealings with the federal government is
possible that stand has I think served
the college well over the years but
nonetheless we're always trolling for
Hillsdale data I regret to say that we
may be forced to drop Hillsdale from the
rankings this year I'm getting a lot of
pressure to do so because of the
difficulties we've added sort of guessed
it guess it some of the data and this is
causing consternation among my some of
my colleagues today though I want to
talk about the federal student financial
aid program programs I really should say
I believe they are costly inefficient
Byzantine do not serve their desired
objectives and in one word are
dysfunctional I use that term to
describe them when I was serving on the
Spelling's Commission on the future of
higher education and that raised quite a
bit of fuss if anything these policies
have moved from being dysfunctional to
being uber dysfunctional amongst the
worse of many bad federal programs
federal student assistant programs can
be rationalized on three grounds first
it's argued that higher education has
enormous positive spillover effects
where when Johnny or Joanne goes to
college their family their friends or
coworkers and so forth derive positive
benefits from their attending second it
is argued that higher education is a
vehicle to promote equal economic
opportunity a ticket to achieving the
American dream in short it promotes
income equality and mobility third with
respect to federal student loans it is
argue that markets for loans for to
college students are in perfect private
markets are imperfect because of a lack
of knowledge on the part of lenders
about students and in the absence of
federal student loan programs too few
students would be going to college this
is an argument off
mate now I think all of these arguments
are dubious at best the alleged positive
external benefits to college are very
difficult to measure and as the late of
Milton Friedman opined to me shortly
before his death may be more offset by
negative externalities or spillover
effects I have he actually Freedman
asked wondered whether we should tax
colleges rather than subsidize I'm not
sure how Hillsdale would take to that I
have tried to measure the economic
spillover effects by looking at the
relationship between spending on higher
ed and the rate of economic growth
looking at state appropriations for each
of the states that have state
universities and what I have found is
that if you would expect if there were
positive spillover effects you would
have higher economic growth the more you
spent on colleges I found the reverse
the more state appropriations go up the
lower of the rate of economic growth or
at or at the minimum it's a non-existent
relationship so as to higher ed higher
education and by inference student loan
programs as a vehicle for income
equality I think it's interesting that
over the last four decades in which the
proportion of adults with four-year
college degrees tripled that income
equality in the United States fell not
rose looking at this issue in elaborate
detail with a colleague Daniel Bennett
we're finding that if in small doses
higher education might have some
egalitarian features but at the level it
operates in American today higher
education actually tends to induce
reduction in income equality now
personally I don't know what the
socially optimal level of inequality is
or equality and the tacit assumption
that more equality is desirable I think
is at least questionable but that isn't
germane to our discussion today in
reality higher
education is not promoting income
equality a smaller percentage of
low-income Americans who are recent
college graduates a small smaller
percentage come from the lower income
classes today than in 1970 before we had
Pell grants or much of a student loan
program so these programs have done
nothing to help the poor
at least I as I read it with regards to
that imperfect capital market about
student loans capital markets argument I
think it is likewise very weak every
college student I know has had no
problem acquiring credit cards if
financial institutions can issue can
lend on credit cards to college students
without any difficulty and make car
loans to college students readily and in
large numbers why can't they make
student educational loans perfectly
adequately on their own I think the
short answer is they can that's I think
the intellectual arguments for these
programs are very very weak that said
however these programs exist and are
growing rapidly the Pell Grant program
well over doubled in size between 2007
and 2010 designed to help poor people
the Obama administration is working hard
to make it a middle class entitlement
student loans have been growing eight to
ten percent a year for at least two
decades and is well publicized now
aggregate to one trillion dollars of
debt outstanding roughly of $25,000 or
so on average for the roughly 40 million
holders of that debt student loan debt
is now larger than credit card debt in
the United States
I have always assumed that this debt was
mostly held by young people in their 20s
or at the most early 30s but new Federal
Reserve data show that that isn't the
case the median age of those would loan
obligations today is about 33 and about
40 percent of the debt is held by
persons
forty years of age or older so when the
President and even Governor Romney
talked about maintaining low interest
rate loans he's three point four percent
loans this is not helping kids in
college as much as older middle age in
individuals long gone from the halls of
the Academy now let me outline ten
specific problems I have with federal
student loan programs or grant in some
cases grant programs there are
undoubtedly others but this is going to
be an is an afternoon talk a lunch talk
soon and you want lunch and diminishing
returns and sleep will set in if I give
you more than ten points
the law of diminishing returns first
student loan interest rates are not set
by the forces of demand and supply but
rather by the political process interest
rates are a price used to allocate
scarce resources and when that price is
manipulated by politicians it leads to
distortion in the use of those resources
since student loan interest rates are
always set below market rates in this
case it means that too much money is
borrowed for college given the innate
preferences of borrowers and lenders at
the moment these interest rates some of
them are extremely low with a key rate
being three point four percent which
after adjusting for inflation is
approximately zero moreover both the
President and Governor Romney want to
continue that low interest rate after
July 1 when it is supposed to double
this is going to a great an already bad
problem and a perfect example of a
fundamental problem with represented
democracy I love representative
democracy by the way but it does have
its problems and the problem here is
that politicians will push programs
where the benefits are visible and
immediate at least to them even though
the costs are extraordinarily high but
relatively less visible and not apparent
for
several years that is this the problem
is about three blocks away it's not here
on Massachusetts Avenue Constitution
Avenue in Independence Avenue and in
between yes second this is not the only
variation from the real world of credit
markets in the real world
interest rates vary with the prospect
that the borrower will repay the loan in
the surreal world of student loans the
brilliant student completing an
electrical engineering degree at MIT
pays the same interest rate as the kid
majoring in ethnic studies at Chicago
State University who has a GPA below 2.0
and has already flunked several courses
the MIT student almost certainly will
graduate and get a good job probably
paying at least $50,000 a year whereas
the odds are very high that the Chicago
State student will fail to graduate and
will be lucky to be making $30,000 a
year related to this colleges themselves
have no skid in the game they are
responsible for allowing loan
commitments to occur but when defaults
are extremely high imposing costs on the
taxpayers the colleges who are at least
partially responsible for the default
face no penalties or negative
consequences that's something Congress
could remedy pretty easily by the way
third and arguably the most important
point the federal grant and student loan
programs have contributed to the tuition
price explosion in the United States
when third parties pay a large part of
the bill at least temporarily the
customers demand for the service Rises
and he or she is not terribly sensitive
to price universities and colleges take
advantage of that and raise the prices
to capture the law the funds that are
ostensibly designed to help students
this is actually what happened in
healthcare and is what is happening in
higher
education bill Bennett a loudly observed
this positive relationship between
tuition fees and federal student Alone's
25 years ago when he was the education
secretary and the relationship which is
now called the Bevin hypothesis is as
true now as it was then I talked to mr.
Bennett about it the other day he still
believes in it fourth there is only a
monopoly provider of student loans the
federal government till recently at
least the feds turn the servicing
Alone's over to a variety of private
financial service firms adding an
element of competition and leading these
private providers to buy for business on
the basis of the quality of the service
if not the price but the Obama
administration with its strong hostility
to private enterprise has now decided to
exercise a complete monopoly the post
office can't deliver the mail cheaply
efficiently or profitably
the Division of Motor Vehicles in any
state government is notoriously
inefficient with long lines and nasty
employees servicing customers why should
the federal government monopoly be any
different with respect to student loans
by the way because of highly
irresponsible fiscal policies remember
the federal government borrows 30 or 40
percent of the money it spends at the
margin the student loan program is
arguably financed by government
borrowing much from overseas thus we are
incurring long-term obligation to
foreigners to finance loans to largely
middle-class Americans to go to college
is this an appropriate use of public
funds at a time of significant federal
budget deficits 5th those applying for
student loans or Pell grants are
compelled to complete the FAFSA form
this is a problem on multiple levels
first of all for the forum throughout
most of its history has been extremely
complex
comprising more than 100 questions my
wife a long time high school guidance
counselor in a very poor area have long
told me that the single greatest
obstacle to getting poor kids into
college was the fact that most of the
students parents simply refused to fill
out the FAFSA form secondary second in a
secondary point is that the form is also
used by colleges to administer so-called
scholarships that is to say tuition
discounts given to some students but not
to others those colleges are given all
sorts of highly personal and private
information on family incomes wealth
debt child support and so forth imagine
going to a car dealer and asking how
much a car costs only to be told that
you will get that information only after
you tell the dealer all sorts of
personal financial information that then
will enable the dealers to see how much
he can gouge you given your financial
situation that car dealer would either
be out of business or in jail within
days or weeks this is commonplace in
higher education and exists because of
the so called federal student financial
assistance programs this brings me to a
related a six point partly because of
the validity of the Bennett hypothesis
partly because of the impact of the
FAFSA form and reduce the applications
of low income persons for college aid
and no doubt for other reasons relating
the fact that many colleges gauge
success partly on the basis of the
number of customers they turn away the
relationship between college degree
attainment and income equality these
days is in fact negative the larger
proportion of adults with college
degrees in a state the higher the degree
of income inequality in the state and I
think student loans have had a role to
play in this seventh the federal
programs have been successful in
increasing the number of students enroll
in college no doubt about that
more kids go to college but that has led
to two big problems first the number of
college graduates annually now far
exceeds the number of new managerial
technical and professional jobs jobs
that traditionally went to college
graduates after they finished school one
survey by Northeastern University
estimates that over half of recent
college graduates are underemployed or
unemployed or as one of these
individuals put it in an email to me
recently mal employed a term I rather
like I went I wanted to hire that kid on
the spot for that coming up with that
term we are now in a world with a
hundred and seven thousand statistics so
here they are
we're now in a world with a hundred and
seven thousand janitors with bachelor's
degrees not to mention over 16,000
parking lot attendants do you really
need a bachelor's degree to be a
bartender hairdresser or mail carrier
lots of persons in these occupations
have such degrees and many of them are
struggling to pay off their loan
obligations with their very limited
incomes all of the marek mail carriers
do pretty well which is one reason why
the post office is going broke the
second huge problem that enrollment
increases induced by federal student
loan programs have caused relates to
academic quality more and more kids are
going to college who lack the cognitive
skills the discipline the academic
preparation and or the ambition to
succeed academically they simply cannot
or do not master well much of the rather
complex materials that college students
are expected to learn the consequences
of this are twofold first a lot of these
students either do not graduate or fail
to graduate on time I've estimated that
only 40% or less a Pell Grant recipients
actually get degrees within six years an
extremely high dropout or failure rate
no one has seriously questioned
statistic a number by the way that the
federal government does not publish no
doubt because it's embarrassingly low
second in an attempt to minimize this
problem colleges have lowered standards
expecting students to read and write
less giving higher grades and true
historically for lesser amounts of work
survey so students spent on average less
than 30 hours a week on all aspects of
academic work less than they spend on
recreation you know what recreation is
to college students but this is a family
television show a presentation as a room
and rosca showed in academically adrift
critical thinking skills amongst college
seniors on average are embarrassing
little more than among freshmen the a
problem with student loans who suggested
me a couple of days ago by a North
Carolina judge who wrote me and who
shared a news story relating to a case
in his courtroom about student loan
fraud with super low interest rates
there's a huge temptation for persons to
pretend to have an interest in higher
education acquire a 3.4 percent loan
drop out of school quickly and use the
proceeds for other purposes such as in
the North Carolina case starting a
t-shirt business this gives those
misusing student loans and unfair
competitive advantage over others who
have to borrow at market interest rates
ninth one of my students suggested to me
that there's big money to be made in the
markets for something called student
loan asset based securities or I love
these slabs the implication being that
the government protection against
default allows speculators and bundled
loan packages to make huge profits I
haven't researched this in detail but I
can see where it might lead to
undesirable unattended consequences temp
poor and mediocre students can get
greater subsidies than hard-working and
industrious one
take the Pell grants a student who works
extra hard and graduates with great
grades after only three years will only
get half as much money as the mediocre
student who flunked several courses and
takes six years and maybe doesn't even
finish her degree there are actually
disincentives to excel academically okay
what do we do about all this it is clear
that the current system needs to undergo
radical change the simplest solution
would be to simply eliminate all federal
student loans and grant programs almost
overnight but aside from being totally
infeasible from a political perspective
there are some legitimate equity issues
that this would raise for example a
student depending on federally
subsidized loans to finance or college
education would likely be in a sad
situation if those loads were suddenly
dried up at the minimum students in the
loan in the grant and loan pipeline
should arguably be allowed to finish
their studies with continued financial
support a variant would be to
grandfather existing recipients and to
deny aid to future potential students
but even here however one would hear
cries of I have prepared for college
thinking I would be receiving a student
loan that is no longer available
nonetheless this would be a better
solution than what we have now the
justification for federal subsidies
relating to issues of access equality
and positive spillover effects seem to
be empirically wanting the federal
government is vastly overextended
fiscally thus a relatively rapid but
UMaine phasing out of the programs would
seem highly desirable I'm speaking
mainly about the lone student loan
programs here there's a slightly
different arguments can be made with
respect to Pell grants but since I the
emphasis today is on student loans I
would point out in the error before
these programs were large say the 1950s
and 1960s higher education was in its
golden a
enrollments were rising lower incomes a
student access was actually growing and
American leadership in higher education
became well-established we flourished
without these kinds of programs much of
the vast funding increase has
contributed to an unproductive academic
arms race that has led to bloated
university bureaucracies to higher costs
of schooling and probably to some
significant decline in academic quality
if the law of act of unintended
consequences ever applied it is in
federal student financial assistance
programs created often with the the
noblest of intentions have failed to
serve their customers or the nation well
there are compromised measures that
would sharply reduce the size of these
programs and improve their functionality
but if past experience is any guide
Congress to gain political points with
some constituency would likely
ultimately restore them to their
dysfunctional current role as the ratio
of debt to GDP continues to rise
nationally and higher education
continues to spend inordinate
unsustainably along at a long-term pace
radical change will come to the Academy
the current situation is unsustainable
economically but
reforming federal financial aid policies
would be a good place to start that
reform thank you very much
we now have time for a few questions so
we have a couple microphones we just ask
that you raise your hand and wait for
one of them to come to you thank you sir
I'm I'm excited to hear Austrian
economics being said and I'm curious to
know are you being allowed to say this
kind of thing on campuses are you being
invited three blocks away to the halls
of power to to say this where where you
can drive it home well that is a most
interesting question I have been
teaching for 47 years and tenure has a
lot of inefficiencies associated with it
but it has advantages retirement even
adds to that I can say anything I darn
well want to anyone and do I used to I I
must say in fairness I received a call
from a congressman fact that congressman
wanted me to come over and see him
before this lecture I couldn't go
because of time constraints I've agreed
to meet with him next week I had their
arse I've talked to several congressman
congressman Ryan and I have had some
interesting conversations on these
issues and he's kind of a thoughtful
long-run kind of guy I think and you may
have some interesting I think he's
willing to is open to new ways of
dealing with this problem so there is
some of this in the Academy I give a lot
of talks to different schools I've been
at such schools as University of Vermont
University of Wisconsin in recent weeks
Dartmouth College Princeton University
I'm going to UCLA next month
or in about two weeks old that's a group
of libertarians inviting me out there
I'd say a group probably three up that
are inviting me out so I have to be fair
but there is a lot of problems in the
Academy with sort of intimidation and
intolerance against unpopular ideas and
I face that some I was I I needed I have
needed police protection on two times
where I've had to speak I'm serious
about this I've actually had to have
police protection once I was a
supporting Sweatshops I think that
rather nice at the University of
Michigan and that didn't go over well
and and I had a group of African
American scholars mad at me because I
questioned whether we should continue to
have historically black colleges and
universities based on race I mean I'm
not against the institution's but basing
the institution on its racial
composition I questioned whether that is
is an outmoded concept so I get a lot of
hostility from time to time but look at
if this is a free country and we believe
in the First Amendment and we believe in
free ideas and we believe in
representative democracy if not me who
and not not now when Professor the
administration and others frequently
point the finger at private
profit-making institutions as being the
major leader in default do you find this
a major problem it it is there's a lot
of dissing there's a lot of disingenuous
use of statistics here it is true that
loan default rates amongst those who go
to the so-called for-profit universities
are somewhat higher than the default
rates among other you schools although I
would add majority of defaults a large
majority of faults occur in traditional
not-for-profit institutions but you have
to remember the for-profit institutions
also serve entirely different kind of
clientele than the typical college and
universities a vast majority of the
students and many of these for-profit
schools are non-traditional students
first-generation college students are
members of minority groups and so forth
of groups for which default rates have
historically been high the the
for-profit schools have taken advantage
of these programs like anyone else but I
think the the hostility towards profit
in for-profit in
to shion's is almost pathologically
unsound
and i have been a strong supporter of
these institution by the way on average
my opinion is these institutions are
more student-centered the two groups in
America of in higher ed that are
student-centered are the traditional
not-for-profit liberal arts colleges of
which Hillsdale is a marvelous example
I've visited Hillsdale on more than one
occasion and the other group are the
for-profit schools because students are
their bread and butter that's how they
make money they got to be nice to
students they got a serve students they
got to help them get jobs after they
graduate so I think they've taken a kind
of a bum rap scheana's gonna come from
someone in our online audience Robin
Pohl and she asks it seems to me that
the right to education is part of the
problem and so far as it means that
everyone should go to college
is there such a right well I don't know
it I don't recall in the Bible or in the
founding fathers any talk about the
right to a Pell Grant no one who Pell
was then for whom does the Bell Tolls so
I don't think people manufacture rights
all the time to this and to that and
this is another one of these attempts to
expand entitlement programs by creating
a right it's arguable that there there's
a right of people to live a good life
and to live free without interference
there's arguably a life that government
you could make an argument the
government can maybe push that along in
some cases I suppose but I don't see any
particular right here I actually see
that we have created this horrible
problem as I say of causing great
disappointment and and among young
people a great disillusionment of young
people we we entice them to go to
college President Obama used the term
imperative the other day the the Gates
Foundation issues
similar language the illumina Foundation
issues similar language
I'm not never gonna get money from any
of these people again I did in one case
before ah I think it's wrong to say
these things to get you must go to
college I should most students after
they graduate from high school have some
training that would prepare them for
some sort of job I guess the answer to
that is yes sometimes that train comes
on the job itself sometimes that
training comes from going to a truck
driving school for a year in getting a
certificate or becoming an apprentice to
become a plumber what's wrong with being
a plumber is there anything wrong with
being a plumber we can't all be college
professor sense ain't God so you know I
I always agree with the late Bill
Buckley who said he'd rather be governed
by the first hundred names in the Boston
telephone directory than the faculty at
Harvard College and and I think that
applies today although telephone
directories are going by the wayside
I've noticed
yes well inserting the mic so but there
are several questions up here sir
early in your presentation you discussed
the demographics of who owes this money
yeah and have you done any analysis of
that group which appears to be in the 30
and 40 year old contingent so to speak
those people who took up education
college education later in their life or
people who have just refused right back
that's a wonderful question and I don't
know the answer this Terrorizer I think
there people are looking into that a lot
one group that has rolled up a huge
percentage of the debt are these and
what you know $100,000 150 thousand
dollar loans to professional people a
lawyers and doctors and you know you
don't even finish getting through school
some cases till you're 30 years old or
older so I could see if a person
graduates with a law degree with a
hundred and fifty
thousand dollar debt and I know one such
person who's now in her mid-30s making
$55,000 as a system prosecutor and
paying 150 thousand debt it takes a long
time to pay off a debt at that rate by
the way the president has also said well
after so many years we're going to
forgive the rest of the debt and you
only all have to pay ten percent of your
income and you put in provisions like
that which is a step in the direction of
forgiveness and if we move to student
loan forgiveness we will go the same way
as Greece as a nation and we will if we
don't ultimately default we will be in a
real tough time and we're sending a very
very bad message I think they Occupy
Wall Street people have talked about
let's forgive student debts sounds nice
doesn't it
sounds nice I I said in an article it
was the second worst idea ever it's the
first I was asked what was the first
idea I said creating the loan programs
in the first place
and it it would cause every student
America tomorrow just ignore repayment
as because they say you know they
repaying it for some group why not for
us and and in the hole and no and then
it would be just one federal big
giveaway you know you can borrow any
amount of money and there are limits to
how much you can borrow under various
programs but you can borrow an awful lot
of money under these programs ah and
that was another thing I didn't mention
this money we say why not put a limit on
how much you can borrow 5,000 a year for
six thousand a year we're pushing kids
to apply kids some of them who are not
anywhere near qualified to go to harp I
want to go to expensive school you know
yeah pee-yew one is 40,000 a year as
opposed to the Community College or the
local state university which might be
eight or nine thousand a year and I love
private liberal arts colleges but is it
really the federal government's role to
pay for Cadillac Education
for everyone to do what there's a
microphone issue here get this gentleman
later though he's been trying hard to
get in yes sir to what extent does a
problem you have outlined today
contribute to the decline of technical
schools around the country for a variety
of reasons owing to rising labor cost in
China and the discovery that we sit at
top abundant resources of natural gas
which means cheaper electricity
manufacturing in the United States is
making a comeback or it's on the cusp of
making a huge comeback but the problem
that the manufacturers discover is lack
of skilled labor because we have been
hurting kids off to college to study
criminal justice which I guess is the
ultimate oxymoron and and we don't have
people who are qualified to take home
the jobs of responsibilities in
manufacturing plants so could you please
address that thank you
yes we don't tool-and-die workers for
example or specialized manufacturing
type jobs or production type jobs where
the average age among those who are
still in those fields is getting very
very high it's getting almost as old as
the average philosophy professor and the
there is a problem there and I never
thought I would say this on in a
audience for Hillsdale College the
Germans do one thing fairly well and
that is they do have fairly decent
vocational programs and they don't look
at college as the where the good people
go the elite the successful people go to
college other people go to vocational
training after high school or even in
the latter part of the high school years
that what we would consider junior and
senior we used to have vocational
schools in this country we still have
some but they have been sort of in
disrepair or just and I think they need
to be revived I think we need to put
more emphasis on that I think the
government should give a lot of vouchers
out not not sponsor schools but give
vouchers let
young adults perhaps high school
graduates go where they want to get some
specialized skill training we do need
people to drive those 18 wheel trucks
down the highway
we need plumbers we need to imbibe
makers all of these things require some
skills some training but they don't
require formal four-year college
education and we should prepare for
those people as well and we've been
neglectful with our audience I think a
little bit irony here is Hillsdale
College students are they have its any
affiliate federal programs available to
them I'm not I don't want to represent
Hillsdale College here and I would defer
to the Hillsdale staff on whether what
what they're allowed to do or not do but
I know that Hillsdale as an institution
has since its founding way back in the
19th century not taken any federal money
am i I hope I no one has disagree me who
represents Hillsdale here I cannot speak
with specific one thing students can do
you know students can borrow there was
nothing wrong with a student borrowing
money from a bank that's not illegal now
you don't get put in jail if you go to
the bank and borrow and a lot of
students borrow they tell me this I
think it's an inefficient way to borrow
they just take their credit cards out
they finance college on their credit
card it's a efficient maybe not and I'm
sure there's kids at Hillsdale that do
that as well
so I'm sure there's some some private
there there's students at Hillsdale with
debt but I don't think the the
administration in Hillsdale is pushing
hard for students to borrow money from
the federal government I don't know what
the specifics are on that yes sir well
well and that's right the default
incidentally there's a big argument
about the magnitude of the defaults and
there is some evidence that the federal
government defines false in a default in
a way that would not pass snuff with in
the private sector in financial
institutions it's true in all the minute
analysis there the federal taxpayers the
taxpayers are picking up the bill in a
default it is true that if if a student
pays half of their loan back and then
doesn't pay the other half back because
they default or they've gone into
bankruptcy or whatever the government is
getting something out of it if we just
forgive everyone you know Warren
Buffett's grandchildren if he has any on
student loans from paying anything back
we've have a highly inefficient system
where we're giving money out to higher
income people I know I know some fairly
affluent kids that borrowing money their
parents say I have told them all right
we've told our kids to borrow money at
three point four because we can't borrow
at that and so they tell their kids to
borrow money at three point four I've
had kids come up to me and they say well
I take some I've used some of my student
loan money to start businesses and all
this it's it's against the law it's
fraudulent it happens all the time
I wish we knew the magnitudes of some of
those things we have an additional
question from Doug Orson online viewer
he said our local high school claims
their goal is to get all of their
graduates into a college it seems a lot
of high schools in the region have this
same goal why is this attitude so
prevalent among our educators well the
the Holy Grail is
college it if you Americans have been
led to believe that college is the path
to success so high schools high school
principals will say we want every one of
our kid to be a successful participant
in the American dream it's a noble
thought and a noble objective I think
the reality I think it is that that it
forty fifty years ago
this a goal would have had it resonated
a little better because we didn't have
this problem of Mal employment of
college graduates to the extent that we
do today and the goal would have been
more meaningful I think it it is not
imperative that every student after high
school do anything
I think that's an individual choice
individual freedom should prevail and I
don't know that the government should be
telling people what to do or even high
school principals and superintendents
but I do think you know it is probably
true that most persons after they
graduate from high school should do
something to prepare themselves for the
job or I'll be particularly given the
wretched state of secondary education in
the United States but that's a far away
far different thing in saying we want
everyone to go to college yeah dr. Baron
my name is Bruce Payne and I'm from
Fairfax County Virginia and you might
imagine I don't have any kids in the
local schools there however I became
interested in this whole business of
Education and cost when I was our school
district was redistricting and I think
it's a it's an effort or confidence an
effort by the school administration to
kind of homogenized our students to
create a fictitious level of attainment
by those students to chase federal money
and I think I think over the last 20
years we've seen a kind of destruction
of our of our schools our public schools
I like to have you comment on that yes
actually that fits in well with there's
a a sociologist at
Rutgers I usually don't think much as
sociologists this is one I like I
probably like him because he got his PhD
in 1951 from Harvard and he's still
going strong at the age of I don't know
120 whatever he is up his name is
Jackson
Toby he wrote a book a year or two ago
and his central thesis was that the
lowering of emission standards and so
forth by colleges that is kids can get
in somewhere to college has led the high
schools to lower their standards and you
know kids will push hard in high school
if the consequences of not succeeding is
they can't achieve this their next goal
in life and that the colleges have
contributed to the problems in the in
the public schools I think the public
school problems go deeper than that I
think there's a lot of problems the
certification standards are wrong the
unions have too much power education
colleges I by the way if I were up to me
I would make it I don't like to make too
many crimes because I'm fairly
libertarian an orientation but I think I
would make it a felony for a
superintendent schools knowingly hire a
graduate of a college of education up I
joke in a little bit but only a little
bit we should do away with colleges of
education and the it is true that and I
will say this as a college professor
some of the problems we have in colleges
we inherit we inherit from the K through
12
all right kids that are coming in I've
been teaching for 47 years
I give essay exams I do all sorts of
unfashionable things I where you fill
out blue books and the quality of the
writing has deteriorated a lot over time
for example just to pick one thing I
used to assign six books in my course in
American economic history as required I
assign one now and I pray that they read
it ah
and you say that's my fault I still have
pretty tough grading standards I thought
that would drive the students away for
some reason they keep coming to my class
I have
the only example market failure I've
ever seen and but I really I worry a lot
about qualitative decline in in our
youth they certainly have lost sight of
the core values they don't know about
the founding of our country they don't
know history well enough they don't know
a lot of those things they're very good
at they're they're okay their math
skills are having declined as much as
their skills in other areas but this
lecture is supposed to be about student
loans not about that so perhaps I should
be quiet sir how you doing thank you for
the presentation today obviously this is
a multi-faceted problem
with a loan debt issue with students but
I think the magnitude of the problem
perhaps is partly related to the lack of
cost control on the behalf of the
universities have you looked at that and
do you have some interesting ideas on
what universities could do to help lower
the cost of education which would in
turn lower the cost of you know these
student loans for both the government
and and the people panel oh I love that
question
I wrote us I have a little pamphlet I
didn't bring any copies with me call 25
ways to reduce college costs let's just
mention a few let's start with some
elementary like buildings you go to
General Motors or you go to Microsoft or
Intel the buildings are occupied you go
there Fridays the buildings are occupied
you go there in July the buildings are
occupied you go into a typical
University for months a year the most
classrooms are empty most offices are
empty all the time my department I've
been doing a survey lately and on
average 15 percent of the offices are
occupied at any moment at a time so
there's an enormous space waste I talked
to a for-profit entrepreneur it's higher
education guy about he says we don't
even own buildings we're not in the real
estate bill business we're in the
education business
we lease buildings that way we have
greater flexibility we can expand space
reduce space as we need so there's
enormous a waste on the capital cost
side teaching loads teaching loads when
I started teaching at a typical mid
quality State University where 9 to 12
hours a week 12 hours a week being quite
common now at those schools that they've
fallen by 1/3 to 1/2 and they have at
the quality at the University of
Wisconsin where I was as I mentioned the
other day the standard teaching load for
a full professor in economics or anyone
any economics is one course a year not a
semester a year they got it down from
one a semester one a semester is more
common to a semester is considered a
brutal load I taught three courses
semester when I started teaching on the
semester system managed to polish out a
few books and 150 articles I I worked
hard you know I went to I kind of looked
at it like normal people go to work at
8:30 go home at 5:00 5:30 work a little
bit on the weekends working the summer a
novel idea and I think that that the
work ethic is a little low besides a
huge amount of work in among college
professors is unproductive research work
that should never be published it's the
law of diminishing returns decided how
many articles have been written on
William Shakespeare since 1985 there's
been a gap there's been a debate whether
the number is as low as 21,000 or as
high as 35,000 and I had the audacity at
a meeting the other day say don't we
know everything we need to know about
the bard or are we reaching diminishing
returns anyway and the studying of the
bar I love Shakespeare
but he died in 1615 and the time has
come maybe to only have 50 articles a
year on ships and God was I eaten alive
so there are lots of things like this
the administrative staffs at
universities have become incredibly
bloated the typical university has as
many men as
traitors as it does faculty members and
schools like Hillsdale probably avoid
summer because they don't have to deal
with the federal government so they they
cut out some of that but there's just
enormous my university has a
sustainability coordinator whatever that
is we have a recycling coordinator
whatever that is and do you really need
to hire a lot of people to sit around
and tell about Bonneville earth and why
we should buy our vegetables locally
rather than in an efficient way
Kroger's made some cases in other
countries you know we pay people to
proselytize this junk there's this Sun
sounds and that this is true all over
you know throughout may probably not at
Hillsdale but it's true at most schools
and there's a lot of wastage just a lot
I could go on and on really do libraries
need to buy I love books I have a huge
library but this pains me to say but do
libraries need to buy fifty thousand
hundred thousand volumes a year anymore
a lot of them are being digitized put on
by Google and others can't we have
central libraries where you can go to
get your books can't you have
cooperative Library Association's
there's some of this going on in higher
ed by the way I don't want to say
there's none of this kind of activity
going on but there's just so many ways
we could save money I I often say I once
said give me the faculty make me
president of my University for one month
cut my teaching load in half for that
month let me work half day in the
president's office half day in my office
and I will save twenty million dollars
by the end of the month I and one other
thing give me a copy of the phone
directory I'll just go through with a
yellow pen and just wipe out to 300
administrative jobs the place with would
hum it work better because we don't have
is now we only have to go through two
layers of bureaucracy to get something
done instead of four and it would it
would hum and which I save 20 million
bucks which you know not chicken feed in
my little school a thousand dollars a
student
ah and I that's true at most
this will be our final question about
one of the other things that you
referred to early in your presentation
when you said that you've studied the
states and found a correlation in those
states where there's a high percentage
of college grads with a greater
disproportionate economic achievement
can you give us a little background to
that because what went through my mind
the first question this is because the
high number of people who are graduates
of college are making all the money and
the people who didn't go to college
aren't making money as a possibility
that's an excellent question and by the
way this is research that's still
ongoing it's I've been working on it for
the last couple months it's it's pretty
well documented now and we're getting
good statistical results I'm still in my
own mind trying to figure out why this
is so and I think you're asking an
excellent question where you that there
does to see for example New York is a
state with enormous income inequality as
measured by standard statistics but it
also has very high percentage of college
attainment but it also has Wall Street
it also has a lot of 10 and 20 million
dollar-a-year people which when you do
the statistical calculations of
inequality tend to raise that those
statistics a lot and I'm trying and I
want to try I'm I was a little premature
in making the statement I did I think
it's true actually it's true but I don't
have a complete handle on why and I
wanted that's the next stage in my
research is to try to look at what other
characteristics are there in these areas
where you have high college attainment
you have a high inequality what else is
going on in those states and I'm still
in the process of doing I think you hit
on part of it is a college graduates
incomes get some of them gets
upwards anytime you have Oprah Winfrey
in your sample or Tim Tebow or the
Zuckerberg ideal he didn't go to cuz you
know a lot of these yeah he went to call
a lot of never you know gates and all
these Gates is trying to get everyone to
go to college even though he didn't
himself I mean he did but he didn't
graduate it's certainly the irony of the
non college graduate who's pushing
college graduations well it's kind of
funny things ironic things I've enjoyed
being here very much
and I want to thank you am I is I'm
doing the right thing here I want to
thank you for coming and I want to thank
Hillsdale College one of the really
premier educational institutions aren't
country one of the unique educational
institutions our country for inviting me
so thank you very much
Thank You professor better that was most
enlightening and goes to show that
economics is not the dismal science it
is just after exam time at Hillsdale
College our commencement is Saturday and
your reference to the following
standards of final exams and courses in
general reminds me of my favorite entry
in a blue book and that was a student
attempting to quote Madison's famous
quotation men are not angels wrote
instead men are not angles I understood
what they meant will now have lunch and
invite you all to go downstairs there's
an elevator
they're also stairs downstairs it's a
lovely day outside we'd invite you to
join us on the terrace or anywhere else
in the building that you would like to
eat I should mention two upcoming events
on the month of June this lecture series
will as with today and also our next
time and probably in times thereafter
depart from the first Friday
we try to keep it to to that timeframe
and and may do so in the future but our
next talk actually falls on a Monday
Monday June the 4th we'll have a talk
from gretchen morgenson
a former editor at forbes and and worth
magazine miss Morgenson now writes for
the New York Times and covers Wall
Street her topic is the 2008 housing
crisis and the lack of accountability
for that thing she's written a book
reckless endangerment to that subject
and will be summarizing some of her more
recent thoughts on that important topic
in the latter part of that week then we
welcome each summer a group of Hillsdale
College students for 40 years we've been
sending our undergrads to Washington and
on Friday June 8th we'll welcome our
incoming class of Washington Hillsdale
internship program participants also
about 3540 Hillsdale College students
will be coming and
to welcome them we're going to have a
talk with the title of why is Thomas
Moore the patron of politicians so
that's the kind of thing that blends
their studies and what we do here at the
Kirby Center we think we'll also be
pleased to have the the giver of that
presentation Steven Smith the scholar of
Shakespeare who might want to talk to
you about professor Vetter
he teaches Dante and Thomas Moore and
has done some really wonderful recent
work on on Thomas Moore and so we'll be
giving that presentation it's going to
be kind of a convivial time so it'll be
refreshments and food that evening
Friday June the 8th so then please join
us for lunch thank you very much for
coming today